Comme vous le savez, la langue française est réputée pour sa complexité.
Une complexité qui en fait la richesse mais qui la rend aussi
extrêmement difficile à maîtriser.
À tel point que même ceux dont le français est la langue maternelle ont parfois du mal à s'y retrouver...
Et en tant qu'enseignant amoureux de la langue de Molière,
je peux vous assurer que s'exprimer dans notre langue sans faire d'erreur relève parfois de l'exploit militaire.
Dans cette vidéo, je vais vous présenter
10 fautes de français que nous faisons presque tous sans le savoir.
Et je ne vous parle pas de fautes que tout le monde connaît déjà,
comme "je vais au coiffeur", "ils croivent", ou encore le fameux "je sais pas c'est quoi".
Rétablissement de la roue pour celui-là.
Là, je vous parle de fautes que même des gens instruits peuvent commettre,
des fautes que vous faites peut-être vous-même.
Alors est-ce que vous serez capable de repérer ces fautes ?
C'est ce qu'on va voir, soyez attentifs, c'est parti !
*Et... T'envoies pas le générique ?...*
Non, pas aujourd'hui.
*D'accord.*
Je fais ce que je veux.
Eh bien non : contrairement à ce qu'on entend souvent, on ne pallie pas à quelque chose, on pallie quelque chose.
"Pallier" appartient à la catégorie des verbe transitifs directs,
ce qui veut dire qu'il est suivi d'un COD et non d'un COI.
On remédie À une situation, mais on pallie UNE situation. Oui.
"J'ai été", c'est le passé composé du verbe être, comme dans la phrase "j'ai été stupide de faire ça".
Techniquement, cette tournure de phrase n'est donc pas incorrecte.
Mais ça n'a rien à voir avec le fait d'ALLER au cinéma, qui est le véritable sens de cette phrase.
On doit donc dire : "je suis allé au cinéma", et non pas "j'ai été au cinéma".
Mmh, là c'est plus dur...
Un paradoxe, c'est quelque chose qui a l'air contradictoire, mais qui en réalité n'est pas contradictoire.
Par exemple, il est paradoxal d'être fatigué alors qu'on n'a rien foutu de sa journée.
Mais ce n'est pas contradictoire parce que... c'est possible !
Donc quand vous dites : "Ça semble paradoxal", vous dites en fait : "Ça semble sembler contradictoire".
Vous voyez le problème ?
On dira donc : "c'est paradoxal", ou "ça semble contradictoire", mais pas "ça semble paradoxal".
Alors celui-là il a le don de m'énerver...
On va expliquer ça calmement.
"Hui", c'est l'ancien mot pour dire "ce jour".
"Aujourd'hui", c'est donc déjà un pléonasme
puisque ça veut dire : "au jour de ce jour".
Mais l'usage faisant loi, on a fini par accepter l'emploi de l'expression
"aujourd'hui" pourtant incorrecte sur le plan grammatical.
Mais si en plus vous dites "au jour d'aujourd'hui",
vous faites un double pléonasme, puisque vous dites : "au jour du jour de ce jour".
Et là, tout ce que vous méritez,
c'est un bon tacle à la carotide.
Je vous l'ai dit, ça m'énerve.
Alors ici le problème est multiple, puisque déjà, on ne dit pas UNE aparté mais UN aparté.
Mais aussi parce que, par définition,
un aparté,
c'est toujours petit.
Au théâtre, un aparté désigne les paroles prononcées par un personnage et que les autres personnages présents sur scène ne sont pas
censés entendre.
Donc vous imaginez bien que si l'aparté dure trois plombes,
cela devient compliqué de faire croire au spectateur que les autres ne l'entendent pas.
Pour finir, il ne faut pas confondre un aparté et une
digression.
La plupart du temps, quand on dit qu'on fait un aparté,
On veut dire qu'on va apporter un développement annexe au sujet principal.
Mais cela n'a rien à voir avec un aparté, puisque si les personnes présentes
entendent ce qu'on dit,
ce n'est plus un aparté...
Alors là, on est typiquement dans le genre de fautes que même des gens lettrés commettent.
Voilà en quoi cette tournure de phrase est incorrecte. Soyez attentifs, c'est juste un peu plus technique.
"Dont" est un pronom relatif qui s'utilise en reprise de la préposition "de".
Un exemple simple : "je lui ai parlé de ce restaurant" devient :
"c'est le restaurant dont je lui ai parlé".
On emploie le mot "dont" car, dans la phrase précédente,
on parlait "de" quelque chose.
Donc si vous dites : "c'est de cela dont il s'agit",
c'est comme si vous disiez deux fois "de".
La tournure correcte est : "c'est cela dont il s'agit".
Vous pouvez aussi dire : "c'est de cela qu'il s'agit". DE cela QU"il s'agit.
C'est l'un ou l'autre, mais pas les deux.
Et ouais, faut faire des choix dans la vie.
Erreur courante bien compréhensible puisque dans notre esprit, "mémoire",
"mémorisation", "mémotechnique", ça paraît logique...
Eh bien non.
On dit "mnémotechnique".
Mnemo, du nom de la déesse grecque Mnémosyne, qu'on retrouve d'ailleurs dans le mot
"amnésique", qui signifie "absence de mémoire, oubli".
Voilà.
On dit "et cetera". "Et".
Pas "ex", "et cetera". C'est quand même pas compliqué ! "Et c..."
En latin, la lettre "c" se prononce comme un "k", on dira :
"et ketera", ce qui veut dire littéralement "et le reste".
Prononcé à la française, le [k] devient un [s], mais les lettres sont les mêmes : ETC,
et cetera.
Bon, il y a pire comme erreur, on est d'accord.
Là encore, une erreur courante. Vous allez voir, c'est simple à comprendre.
Quel est l'infinitif de ce verbe ?
C'est "s'ensuivre", en un seul mot.
La preuve, c'est qu'au présent, on dit bien "il s'ensuit que", tout attaché.
Donc il n'y a
aucune raison de couper le mot en deux sous prétexte qu'on le conjugue au passé composé.
On ne dira donc pas "il s'en est suivi"
mais "il s'est ensuivi", tout simplement.
Alors celui-là je l'aime bien parce que moi-même je l'utilise souvent...
Ou je l'utilise souvent parce que je l'aime bien ?...
Je ne sais pas.
Je ne sais plus...
"Donc, du coup", c'est évidemment une redondance, puisque "du coup" et "donc", cela veut dire la même chose.
On ne s'attardera pas sur le fait que l'Académie française rejette l'emploi de l'allocution "du coup" comme synonyme de "donc".
Ne me demandez pas pourquoi,
c'est comme ça.
Ni sur le fait que quand on commence une phrase par "donc, du coup" alors qu'il n'y a aucun lien de causalité avec ce qu'on
vient de dire,
bah, c'est un peu gênant...
Conclusion : on dira soit "donc", soit "du coup", mais pas "donc, du coup".
Voilà, ce classement des 10 fautes de français que nous faisons presque tous est maintenant terminé.
Si vous connaissez d'autres fautes courantes que vous voulez
me suggérer pour une prochaine vidéo, je vous donne rendez-vous sur ma page Facebook, "Le Précepteur".
J'ai créé une publication sur laquelle vous pourrez poster vos propositions,
le lien est dans la description.
N'oubliez pas de vous abonner, de partager la vidéo.
Je vous invite également à liker la page Facebook...
*À AIMER la page Facebook, b*** !*
... À aimer la page Facebook.
Rejoignez-moi sur Instagram, "charles_precepteur",
et un grand merci aux tipeurs, vous êtes de plus en plus nombreux, merci, merci infiniment.
Je vous dis à bientôt pour un prochain épisode !